how about you use your body to pay
know what
many performers real-life nerves turned
out to be very handy on the set of squid
game the only thing worse than watching
the intensely terrifying games played in
squid game would be doing them but that
was the reality for the whole cast who
were often challenged mentally and
physically with such difficult material
if you haven't binged the entire wild
series yet consider this year's spoiler
alert one of the children's games with a
twist played during squid game was tug
of war
a game that is hardly ever actually
played and when it is usually by
children while the simple battle doesn't
feel too high stakes the consequences of
losing this game were fatal it was also
very dangerous to film on set the amped
up game of tug of war was filmed while
the actors were standing on raised
platforms so when one team lost those
people literally fell down and had a
terrifying experience
not only was it scary there were
definite risks of injury as they flew
off these platforms only further
intensifying the energy of the scene
my god i can't believe how cool that was
the creative team didn't want the actors
to fake it so everyone dove right in
while it was nerve-racking the actors
had to commit to their performances
fully meaning all that strength exerted
and sweat we see is one hundred percent
real
before
on top of the danger elements what we
don't really consider is just how much
more intense the game is when full-grown
adults are playing luckily no one was
badly injured while filming you know
what i really thought we were going to
die out there
filming the glass stones game was
actually terrifying for many of the
actors facing the nerve-wracking game
while they weren't set up at the
death-defying height we see in the show
they were still about a meter and a half
up and that height alone was enough to
make nerves settle in the performers
were walking on pieces of plexiglass
that could break from underneath them at
any time
before the time came to actually shoot
the high intensity scene the actors
nerves were very present and they didn't
go away while filming either the game
never got any easier and while the
actor's hesitance and worry about
filming the sequence could have ruined
the takes it actually wound up being the
best thing
we're in hell here there's no rules in
hell
the intensity of the frightening tasks
was amplified and made these scenes even
stronger the camera doesn't lie and was
able to capture just how stiff and rigid
the actors bodies were adding an extra
layer of freaky realism to the scene as
we saw them genuinely struggle to face
their fears of course filming on a
precarious set was just one hurdle
considering how intense the content was
and how high the stakes were
psychologically the actors definitely
struggled with the whole process and
with very good reason luckily it all
worked out very well for the show we
absolutely feel the terror of these
performers through the screen
oh it's getting exciting
typically when a production has stunts
and scenes as risky and dangerous as
what we see being done in the squid game
there are a whole crew of stunt doubles
specially trained to face the danger
safely and take over when the cameras
were rolling practically it makes sense
the stunt doubles need to be there to
take center stage and perform so the
actors don't risk injury but in the case
of squid game the spotlight was on the
performers
they may have been children's games but
these were some very adult versions
falling from heights exerting great
physical strength and terrifyingly
stepping on glass stones that could
break at any second was just another day
at work for the squid game crew this is
a major testament to just how dedicated
the cast and crew were to telling and
depicting the story of the series as
honestly as possible it's our lives
we're betting on right now
and we gotta win the very first of the
squid game installments was the simple
childhood red light green light game and
while it seems innocent enough it was
far from fun having to freeze was really
tough since the performers had to
pretend to be so terrified and worried
they could lose their life because of
the slightest movement at the wrong time
the environment really just made
everything even more uncomfortable since
there was such a large crowd dressed
almost identically really inspiring a
bit of a freak mob mentality we're like
a bunch of soldiers at training camp huh
there were moments filming for the
actors that felt just a bit too much
like real life and mentally the
performers could struggle with negative
and dark thoughts this team committed to
their craft and put so much of
themselves into it that by the end of
the day many could feel depleted and
overwhelmed by the experience and some
were just frustrated with their
character's choices and what they needed
the 218 actor even expressed extreme
anxiety when preparing to do his role
but thanks to their awesome director he
felt confident in their work and the
script and managed to perform
the squid game premises is wild and part
of what makes it so unsettling is the
freaky and intricate sets the colors
shapes and styles give off unnerving and
creepy vibes so it's no surprise that
the first day the actors saw where they
would be filming their cameras were
immediately whipped out to capture
photos of it all
while it may have seemed like a dream
more often than not the circumstances
felt like a total nightmare being on
some of the bright and happy sets that
induced a sort of feeling of fantasy
could feel like being in a different
world but in conjunction with the
disturbing content being depicted the
scenes became much worse to endure the
sheer range of realistic sets is
impressive the actors appeared to be
outdoors or in the alleyways from when
they were children but it was all just
an illusion adding even more to the
creep factor
it's no surprise some of the actors felt
mentally challenged and drained while
working in these unnerving environments
you saved me
this show wouldn't have worked in
bringing the gruesome and intense
content to the screen had it not been
for the director's vision to make sure
he could get the strongest reactions
from the actors the leader of the team
made the performers feel safe enough to
trust him on the journey this allowed
the intense approach they took by having
all the actors do the games for real
without the fatal consequences of course
by placing the actors in overwhelming
scenarios where their adrenaline would
naturally run high the team managed to
capture some very honest and intense
performances
why did you do that to us
while the actors knew they wouldn't get
any more money than just their paychecks
for their performances that didn't stop
one actor from thinking about what he
might do if he had the opportunity to
play this unbelievable game in real life
the actor who plays the cop in the show
might not go toe-to-toe with the other
actors on set but he's the most likely
of them all to do the game in real life
if given the chance
the actor has confirmed that he'd
consider the daring task with a cash
reward that obviously can convince
people to risk everything
how much do we get the total prize money
is 45.6 billion won
it's no surprise such an intense show
was filled with crazy and unnerving
experiences
luckily those nerves did come in handy
every now and then to depict just how
terrifying the whole premise was which
game freaks you out the most